welcome back to pierce organization
prosecutors have released damaging new
details on why they charged movie star
Alec Baldwin over Helena hutchins's
death on the set of rust New Mexico
prosecutors claim that Ballroom was
distracted and talking on his phone
during mandatory firearms training he
also dispute Baldwin's claim that he
never actually pulled the trigger well
joining me now is lawyer Mark geringos
Hollywood star lawyer Mark is a very
complex case this
but these new details which were in the
court filings I would argue make Alec
Baldwin's position a lot more precarious
than people may have thought originally
because it goes into the detail of why
the prosecutors decided to throw the
book at him and on the face of it these
are damning damning things he wasn't
present but his initial required
firearms training he then received a
30-minute onset training where she
repeatedly took calls for his family on
the phone this is according to the set's
armorer they claim uh he exhibited
Reckless Behavior on set pointed a fire
on the Helena Hutchins who ultimately
died in the lead-up to the incident
violating gun safety rules and so on and
so on they also say that there's clear
evidence contradicting his claim that he
did not pull the trigger they say photos
and videos clearly so Baldwin multiple
times with his finger inside the trigger
guard and on the trigger in the lead up
to the shooting you put all this
together and it's quite easy to work out
why they've decided to go for him
I think that's an accurate summary and
interestingly woven through the summary
you just gave is that most of the
statements that they have embedded in
this criminal complaint are his own
statements which they have refuted which
is why I think we talked about this
Pierce when he gave that first interview
to Stephanopoulos I was shocked that he
did that because there were at least
three different instances in that
interview that in real time we talked
about where massive mistakes not the
least of which is when he said I didn't
pull the trigger because then they have
not only the videos that show that but
now they have then sent out the gun
itself to the FBI the FBI did their own
testing on it came back and said it's
impossible for this kind of to have gone
off and they're going to have to deal
with that we're going to get into a
battle of the experts there he really
has dug a hole for himself and it's part
of of what you see and you you saw it
for years when you were doing your show
here you often get around these people
who are high profile and famous frankly
where they have a crowd around them who
are advising them or telling them this
is what you have to do to rehabilitate
your image and that is not necessarily
what's best from a criminal defense
perspective right I actually think that
Baldwin talked himself into getting
charged I think that the prosecutors
were probably as offended and outraged
as we all were watching it but this
procession of sort of me I'm the real
victim interviews that Baldwin was
giving the behavior of his wife as well
uh you know and just this constant sort
of refrain that I did absolutely nothing
wrong I feel guilty about nothing I'm
not accountable for anything that
happened I'm not responsible when in
fact not only did he pull the trigger
and that seems pretty clear now which
exposes that Central plank of his
defense as the total lie if that is
indeed the case but secondly he was also
a producer on the show on the film which
as the prosecutors pointed out gave him
an executive responsibility as well so
on on two fronts one the person who
physically pulled it as the actor but
secondly he had responsibility on a
wider uh capacity as a producer
and that's precisely why the prosecution
brought that in and put that in the
complaint by bringing in his role as a
producer as opposed to just being an
actor they're now are going to get all
of the real time back then complaints
about safety complaints about shortcuts
when it comes to costs complaints about
saving money at the expense of safety
people quitting all of that stuff
probably most judges would exclude if
you were just the actor but when you're
the producer those kinds of things are
going to come to play it would not
surprise me by the way at some point to
see the armorer cut a plea deal just as
the assistant did and cooperate against
him which will then box him in if he
gets convicted
um there are two different types of
manslaughter he's been charged with if
he's convicted of the more serious one
what is the maximum sentence he could
end up what what maybe a different way
what is the most likely severe sentence
he could get
the there is a count here there's both
the as you accurately point out there's
a manslaughter there's also the this
kind of use of a gun the use of a gun
has a mandatory no ithians or buts five
years right in prison and that is where
this well part of the reason that
they're not going to I don't think cut a
deal right now is because he's got that
hanging over his head he's going to go
to What's called a preliminary hearing
in the States you have to have a
probable cause proceeding before you can
go to trial or before you're forced to
go to trial they and because of covid
they don't go to a grand jury they have
to have a hearing here in New Mexico
where they where you get a chance at the
witnesses they're going to try
everything to get that particular count
dismissed because until they get that
count dismissed the prosecutor has all
the leverage in this case and is it a
jury trial this
yes it would be ultimately a jury trial
so when it comes to that model I mean
you've been involved in many
high-profile cases involving a lot of
very famous people will it help or
hinder Alec Baldwin his movie star
status when he gets in front of that
jury well you know
it's funny you say that because look
this there's a difference you get a
presumption generally if you're famous
as opposed to Infamous if you're famous
you get the truly a presumption of
innocence and my Duality Baldwin I'm old
enough to remember he has gone to jury
trial in Los Angeles and won many years
ago on a road rage incident and so he's
got that kind of he's got a uh history
there the problem is this is not LA or
New York where his last two criminal
encounters were this is New Mexico and
as one of the criminal defense lawyers I
know who practices in New Mexico said we
um we're not we don't take a liking to
people who come here and go to dude
ranches or movie sets and play with guns
so I you know he's he doesn't have the
natural Edge that he might uh in in LA
or in a New York yeah no I think that's
a very accurate assessment of where he's
going to be it's going to be a
fascinating case Mark Gary was great to
talk to you thank you very much
thank you peers